ずっ(鼻をすする)
ずっ
すっ
えほえほえほ
ううっうううううううううう
ううっううううううううううううう
ううるるるるああああ！！！！！！
いたっ
痛った
待って　待って
痛い　痛い
痛てえ…
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
もうタイトルを見てというか
僕の体を見たらわかると思うんですけども
非常に
太りました
今回は
何かが違う
今回はいつもと何かが違う
そう…
痩せれる気がしないんですよ
えぇマジでもう　体重やっべぇ
俺どうなってんのかな
腹とかもう
ほらもう　わかります？
なんか昔　腹筋とか割れてたんですけど
いまもうほら
もう　なんか
ボーン！！！ってなってるんですよ　こことか
ヤベぇなぁ…
なんかデブ！！ってわけじゃないんですけど
なんかこう　体内的な
体内的な太り方をしてるっていうか
皮下脂肪が厚いっていうのかな…
ただのデブじゃないんだよな　俺
なん、なん、なん、なんだろうなぁ
たぶん東京行ってから　すごい太った気がします
東京行って　なんか
ご飯を食べる機会が増えて
間食も増えて
一日三食ちゃんと食べる機会がありまして
ちゃんとしたお弁当をね
ボリュームマックスのお弁当
一日三食絶対食べる機会があったんで
それでたぶん　超太っちゃったのかなって思います
だって俺一日三食とか食べないもん
良くも悪くも不規則な生活をしてたんで
食べる物が少なかったから
なんとか細かったんですけども
一日三食
そんな食事を夏休みの間ずっと続けてたら…
太りました！！！！！！
まあ、いいことなのかもしれませんが
このおなかで健康って言えますか！？
（ぱちっ）
なにこ…うわぁ～～
わぁ～～～～！！！！！
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁあああああ！！
クソッ
これで健康って言えるのかよ！！
(ドカッ)
俺じゃなくなっちまう！！！！
いや、違うだろう
はじめ！！！
はじめお前は…
今までなんて言われてきた！！！！
俺は今までもやし、もやしと言われ
嫌だったけども　ちょっと気に入ってきたりしていて
このままじゃ
(バン！！)
本当にお前もやしじゃなくなるぞ！！！
なんかもうね　太り方
てかたぶんあれですよ
まぁ歳のせいもあると思います
なんやかんやもう24歳なんで
たぶん代謝が悪くなったんで
健康に1日３食おいしく食べていると
間違いなく太りますからね
この年になると…
それで多分太っちゃったのあるし
やっぱ　お菓子とかもたくさん食べてたんで
もう二の腕とかもう　ほら
ヤバ!!!
白っ！！！
あの～～マジで
やばいです。！！
なんか昔着たじゃないですか
金剛金Tシャツでしたっけ？？
なんか、黒いパンパンのTシャツ着たんですけども
あれも一週間続けてみましたが
効果は全くありませんでしたぁ！！！
なぁ～んもなかったよ～、俺はね
結局人間ってな
太るときは太るんだよ…（ドヤ!!）
ちょっと僕しばらく体重量ってないんで
ちょっと今から僕の体重量ってきます
GO!!
これで俺の
今の体重のすべてがわかってしまう！！
行きます！！！！
（じゃかじゃか...）
（どどん！！）
画面汚ねぇな
うわぁぁぁぁぁあぁあああああああ！！！！！！
うぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉ
デブやないかい
え、マジで前回太った時何キロだっけ
多分そのレベルで太ってるんですけど
というわけではじめしゃちょー
今日から！！！！
ダイエットを開始します
いろいろ聞いたんですよ。筋トレしてるサイヤマンさんとかに聞いたんですけど、
痩せたいときはとりあえず食事制限がとても大事らしいです
なんで僕今日を機に、食べ物！マジで変えます
多分もうサラダとか、サラダチキンとかしか食べないような生活をまずは一週間かな
まずは一週間ぐらいちょっとやってみましょう
とりあえず
とりあえず一週間これを続けてみましょう
わかんない、俺の身体の状況によってはもう体重が落ちないかもしれない
とりあえずまずは食事制限でどれだけ落とせるやってみようと思います
というわけでついさっきまで、俺は覚悟を決めて牛丼とまぐろたたき丼を腹いっぱい食ってきて、覚悟をすでに決めております
というわけで今の体重が大体73キロ
ヤバくね!?73キロって俺もう平均だよ!?
モデル体重の俺はどこにいったの？
うわあああああああああああああ！！！！！
はいというわけでみんな覚えとけよ！
この体型覚えとけ、この体型
俺のこの体型を
俺今こんな体型をしていますよ！
うわぁもう全然ガリってないからね!?
ちょっとまずは一週間、いろいろちょっと試して、痩せてみようと思います
いや～でも結局ね、痩せてるほうがかっこいいんですよ
細マッチョっていうかこうやっぱね、すらっとしてるほうがかっこいいのかなってこの......
感じになって思いました
頑張って痩せてみようと思います！
さらばっ！！！